so there was a wonderful article by
Steven Kotler
published in Forbes about how to find
your passion it's a question we ask
ourselves every single day we've all
been told that a life of passion is a
life that means something but how do we
identify our passions it's not always
easy so one of the things that Steven
Kotler breaks down is that he says that
passion essentially exists in the
intersection between multiple things
that you're curious about so he says the
first thing you should do if you want to
identify your passion is to make a list
of all the things that you're curious
about all the things that you wonder
about be as specific as you can and then
create kind of a Venn diagram and try to
figure out where the things that you're
curious about three or more intersect
and that's the sweet spot that's where
there is energy that's where there is
dopamine and neurobiology multiple
streams of curiosity intersected a space
called passion right and then once
you've identified your passion then you
can figure out how to turn that passion
into a purpose turn that passion into a
purpose make a list of 15 things in the
world 15 challenges you'd like to see
solved and then figure out which one of
those challenges can be served by your
passion so then you see curiosity leads
to passion multiple streams of curiosity
leads to passion identifying problems in
the world that can be served by your
passion leads to purpose then my friends
even pregnat in your life with a sense
of significance with a sense of meaning
and then you can go forth my brothers
can go for
I thought it was a great article take
note Steven Cutler's work flow Genome
Project how to find your passion
you